so I think Asians make up like 90  something percent of like I don't  there's they're like typically in the  U.S sorry please don't come at me for  stereotyping but but they they make up a  higher percentage of like like higher  education admission yeah so you're never  gonna have true equality and it's like  me personally so but I'm saying that I'm  saying we should care about men no I'm  saying we should have to say no I'm  saying we shouldn't fight for True  equality because people want to do  different things in different groups and  I'm saying in the top one percent I've  seen what it takes to get there I've  seen firsthand I've seen my dad like  grow up he he worked 60 70 hours a week  he didn't have a life he didn't have  friends most women Valley like we value  a social life we value having fun like  what I've had to do the last three years  to build this like Jess most most girls  would not do it oh no not at all oh no